the year-long intermission is finally
over for the las vegas philharmonic
tickets are on sale for the upcoming
concert series hector mejia sat down
with the conductor to find out how the
symphony orchestra is returning to the
smith center
after the pandemic shutdown
for over a year time stood still inside
reynolds hall at the smith center
not a single soul playing music or
coming to hear it it's our home
and and to step into our home after
being gone for so long is is
is a very special feeling the silence
caused by the pandemic shutdowns
ends this october
with intense rehearsals conductor donato
cabrera in the las vegas philharmonic
get to delight audiences again in
november
there's this sense of nervousness of oh
gosh will i be able to conduct again i
haven't conducted in over a year what
will that be like
and the musicians or this were felt the
same way you know
will i be able to play this hard music
together with six other music violinists
again i know what we know will happen as
well
is within 30 seconds all that will
go away and we'll be so happy to be with
one another
that's what i'm looking forward to the
theme this year is beethoven's
250th birthday we're not able to
celebrate last year
it was his 250th anniversary of his
birth in december of
2020 and we we had grand plans
so we're going to have grand plans again
by celebrating his
birthday all season the orchestra will
perform
all nine of his symphonies along with
music by living american composers
always encourage everyone regardless
if it's music or eating vietnamese food
for the first time
give it a shot we welcome our audiences
we don't
expect them to wear a fancy suit we
don't expect them to know
when to clap and when not to clap we
just want them to
uh experience this beautiful hall that
was built for them
so there you go an open invitation
directly from the conductor
who is also the music director hector
mejia reporting
8 news now opening night november 20th
now ticket packages as we mentioned went
on sale today single tickets will be
available starting september 7th
also students with a valid id get half
off advanced purchase tickets